le mont sima la plus grande station au
nord du 60e parallèle est peut-être la
seule station au monde a compté plus de
champions sur ces pentes que de
kilomètres de pistes
bon sinon c'est la plus belle montagne
pour le début de saison salah au moins
pour cette équipe des stries s'entraîner
à plus de 4300 kilomètres de chez eux
c'est un choix stratégique et climatique
le réchauffement de la planète c'est
toujours difficile au québec
d'abord de la neige au mois de novembre
et car on a montant pas prendre de
chance de ski et au québec où il faut
absolument qu'on veut qu'on fasse un
certain nombre de journées de ski avec
la saison débute et pour ceux qui
viennent ici notre secret un petit
secret qui commence à ne plus en être un
car cette année le mont sima accueilli
des équipes venues de l'ontario du
québec du manitoba de
colombie-britannique d'alberta mais
aussi de ragon d'alaska et même du japon
une opportunité en or pour la station
est comme une sorte de consécration à la
tombée de la nuit les étoiles prennent
possession des lieux
c'est le seul endroit où ce qu'il ya de
la neige ou stocker ce qu'on peut
construire un son adapté pour
s'entraîner l'équipe nationale de surf
des neiges et ses médaillés olympiques
s'entraîne sur le big air des fois en
europe encore tôt comme ceux ci la maj +
de glaciers un peu de plomb est vraiment
un feeling c'est de vraiment puissant
effet et c'est froid et sinon qu'est ça
nous prépare bien
une nouvelle saison va commencer des
jeux olympiques d'hiver approchent alors
qui sait les yukonnais pourront
peut-être dire que c'est sur leur petite
montagne que tout a commencé ici vincent
bonnet radio canada whitehorse